[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm Ben Lazarus The Spectators special
projects editor with 300,000 Israeli
troops amassing near the Gaza border and
the possibility of a ground Invasion
looming Mark regev Benjamin netanyahu's
senior advisor joins me today to discuss
the next steps firstly mark thank you
thank you very much for joining us um
today and what I appreciate It's been a
very difficult and very busy week for
you um just to to start um a senior
Hamas figure said on Wednesday that this
operation took two years in the making
um how did Israeli intelligence manage
to miss it and get it so
wrong so it's clear that there was a
mishap of mistakes something went wrong
something went unfortunately terribly
terribly wrong and the cost in human
life is is is massive and for Israelis
this is particularly annoying because we
pride ourselves on having excellent
intelligence
Services uh and we pride ourselves on
being very good at collecting
information on what our enemies are up
to and so from our point of view this is
unsatisfactory and I'm sure when the
fighting is over there will be
investigations inquiries their lessons
learned to find out why is it I don't
know if it was two years they were
working on it but even if it was just
weeks why is it that they surprised us
the way they did now there's been much
talk this week uh about the potential
for ground Invasion and obviously
there's about 300,000 troops sort of
amassing uh near the Gaza border um
could Hamas be defeated without
launching a ground Invasion and purely
by air
strikes so I'm I'm not at Liberty to
talk about tactics and what and when and
how we're going to attack Hamas I could
only share with you the goals
and the goal is to crush
Hamas and to create a new situation in
Gaza
whereby uh Israelis are no longer uh
threatened the way they have been and
and the goal is to have a situation
where there aren't terrist in Gaza with
either the
desire or the
capability to hit Israel the way Israel
was hit on Saturday morning is there any
way of of achieving that goal and that
that objective without causing Mass
civilian casualties on the Palestinian
side well obviously we don't Target
Palestinian
civilians at the same time we know that
in every armed conflict uh uh uh in
recent history has
involved civilians being caught up in
crossfire and though you don't want to
see civilian casualties that cannot be a
reason not to defend yourself I mean we
didn't want this war Hamas started this
War uh uh uh but we will finish it and
we'll finish it on our terms there's no
point in some sort of quick fix Band-Aid
solution and then when we're just back
to square one and Hamas will attack us
next month or in two months or in half a
year no we want to come out of this with
a new reality in Gaza and that will
require a very very serious military
operation and that is necessary and
that's what the people of Israel demand
now about your question though I want to
say
something there was a war against
Slobodan mosovich over Kosovo where
Britain took the
lead and it was a war to protect
innocent people it was a war to take on
a dictator the war was just but do you
know how many innocent civilians were
killed in that war there has never been
a war without innocent civilians being
caught up and to hold Israel to a
standard that no one else is held to I
think there's something wrong with that
we have the right to defend
ourselves now tell me Mark if um Hamas
is wiped out of the Gaza Strip was to
say that that wouldn't only be a
short-term fix and that later on down
the line there would be an equ uh
militant Jihadi type group that would
just simply replace it um you know the
the sort of military phrase of of mowing
the lawn but you know the lawn will grow
back um is that not a fear down the
line so we're looking at it in your
question we're looking at it through the
concept of what we've been through over
the last decade more than a decade Kamas
has been in power since uh for 16 years
now and we've had ever since Kamas came
to power these intermittent every couple
of years we've had what we've called a a
an operation in Gaza because they were
shooting rockets in Israel and we had to
defend ourselves I want to stress what
we're going through now is not another
Gaza operation by the
IDF This Is War This Is fullscale War
what they did to us on Saturday morning
was was an escalation of massive
proportions and Israel is refusing to go
back to square one we're going to come
out of this as I said with a new reality
in Gaza a different reality Hamas will
be crushed and away from Gaza for a
second how concerned are you by hisbah
in
Lebanon well that's that's actually
another reason why we have to be so uh
forceful and decisively defeat Hamas
because others are watching now Israel
has as many friends in the Middle East
you you know about that there we've got
relationships with Egypt and Jordan and
with Morocco and with the Gulf States
and there's been talk of late of a
breakthrough with Saudi Arabia but there
m enemies of Israel in the Middle East
andah is one of them and they're
watching and and if Israel isn't strong
in our response I'm afraid that the
lesson learned is that you hit Israel
with impunity or relative impunity it's
crucial that Hamas pays a massive price
for its attack upon us that's a lesson
that will be learned by hisbah and that
will also be a lesson that the Iranians
will know you hit Israel you kill our
people you will pay our price that's an
important lesson do you expect his b to
to launch um an offensive against Israel
I mean obviously there's been sort of
skirmishes On the Border in the last
couple of days but do you think anything
might escalate there I think
unfortunately it's possible we don't
want it but Hamas andah are in many way
twins yes they're they're sister
organization
radical terrorists who are in the
Iranian orbit who've been funded and uh
and armed and supported by Iran and it's
clear that there's a a solidarity
between these extremist organizations
and they share the same radical ideology
that Israel has no right to exist not in
any borders yes Israel shouldn't be
there full stop and they're both
terrorist organizations who believe in
killing innocent people and so
kah could try to escalate the situation
and so my message is clear if we were
caught by surprise by Kamas on Saturday
morning we're not going to be caught by
surprise from the north we're ready
we're prepared we don't want a war in
the North but if they force one upon us
as I said we are ready and we will win
decisively in the north too we've
unfortunately had to plan in isra is for
a twoof front War one in the north and
one in the south at the same time we
don't want it as I've said but if we
have to fight it we will and we will
prevail you've mentioned Iran several
times and there's been conflicting
reports about the extent to which Iran
was involved in in the uh events of of
last weekend the Israeli government have
said Iran were involved uh us officials
have denied that Iran was involved to
what extent do you think Iran was
involved in the planning and execution
of those attacks what is public
information we know that Iran andah both
work very closely with Iran specifically
through the Revolutionary
guards uh uh some over 90% 95% if I'm
not mistaken of hamas's budget comes
from the Iranians they have over the
years given them military training
they've given them weapons they've given
them lots and lots of money they've
given them other of sorts of support and
they share the same radical
extreme theology SL
ideology and so they're they're together
and they coordinate closely and they
meet
often uh do they support the sort of
operation that we saw against Israel on
Saturday morning the answer is
unequivocally less because if in London
and in Washington in Paris and Berlin
the operation the the Hamas attack was
condemned it was welcomed inan they were
applauded did the Iranians give the
order for it to happen on a specific day
the way it happened I'm not sure that
we've got evidence of that but I can say
this there's no doubt the Iranians
support and uh uh encourage that sort of
operation is there an argument to be
made that if Iran is uh behind of so
much of um what's going on with Hamas
and hisbah that there might be a case
for uh uh cutting the the head off the
snake directly and launching an attack
on Iran well if if you used a snake
metaphor allow me to use an octopus
metaphor that Israel is fighting the
tentacles but the head is in
Teran and there is a strategic logic in
saying well you're fighting the
tentacles but you can't really win the
war unless you deal with the
head so is that a suggestion that a
direct attack on Iran is not out the
question it's it's it's a suggestion
that we understand the Strategic
situation in which we live nothing more
and let's say there was a a strike on
Iran is there not a huge danger that um
the sheer amount of rockets that are
pointing towards Israel from the Lebanon
border would all suddenly go off and it
would become a very serious existential
risk to the very survival of Israel well
as I said a moment ago we're not
interested in an escalation I said that
and I I say that because I know it to be
true and here I think the Americans have
played a very important role by moving
their Fleet their aircraft carrier task
force to the Eastern Mediterranean they
have sent a message that others should
not try to take advantage of the uh of
the fighting in Gaza and that's an
important message and I hope people uh
in tan and theb leadership are paying
attention and do you believe that Qatar
um um holds any responsibility for these
attacks obviously they shelter the Hamas
leadership I think I think it's a
problem that they shelter the Hamas
leadership let's be Frank this is an
organization that we saw what they
committed the crimes that they committed
Against Humanity against my people
violence that is is is is Isis type
violence and yet the Hamas leadership
sits in Qatar like kings yes hosted by
the Qatari government uh it's
unacceptable and I think there has to be
sanctions against countries that Harbor
these people if you harbored Al-Qaeda
the famous thing after the Attacks of
September 11th is either you're with us
or against us if you hied Al-Qaeda there
you faced Western animosity I think it
should be the same with harboring Kamas
the sort of violence we saw in southern
Israel was Isis type violence in in
today's press conference both prime
minister netan and secrety of State
blink talked about the comparisons
between Isis and Hamas C and so I think
any country that is hosting Hamas
officials there has to be consequences
so would you like to see the UK
government um enact sanctions on qataris
here I mean we we have a lot of Qatari
money swishing around London the qataris
are likely to buy Manchester United
Football Club soon do you see this as
all part you know they presumably
they're buying Manchester United to do a
sort of sports washing of their image um
would you like to see the ukuk do more
to counter the influence of Qatar here I
think any country that is hosting
official representatives of an
organization that that conducted the
sort of violence that we saw horrific
violence that we saw on satday morning
uh there deserved to be
consequences just to talk um about the
violence um that took place on the
weekend on Wednesday there was a lot of
confusion about the um attack on the
kafar AAR Kuts if I'm saying that
correctly and um there was a story of
course about the uh beheading of of
children and babies now it it seems to
take a long time for an official
spokesperson to come out and say whether
that story was correct or not uh which
sort of allowed a confusion to sew
online why was the official announcement
so
slow I think there's there's always
confusion and there's always the rumor
mill and people talk about what they
heard and not what they actually know I
know for a fact that there were examples
of beheadings I have seen pictures of
burnt bodies I've seen pictures of burnt
bodies of
babies but I can't say more than that I
think in all these sort of uh horrific
situations people see different things
people see different stories I can only
tell you what I know to be true and I
have just said
so do you know how many children and Bab
may have may have died in that
Massacre I know quite a number I can't
give you an exact number we know the
overall figure is
1,20 and the overwhelming majority of
them were innocent civilians and we've
seen the pictures of the elderly who
were taken back to Gaza as as as
kidnapped people as hostages we've seen
the children taken back to Gaza as as as
hostages we know of stories where
children were shot in front of their
parents and parents were shot in front
of their children I mean really is Isis
type violence not normal people don't
behead
others now regarding the hostages um
does Israel have any idea under what
conditions they're being held in and and
where they might be being held within
the Gaza
Strip so the working assumption is that
Kamas is separated them and put them in
a number of places for for their own
reasons but I want to say two messages
on the hostages number
one and let me be clear Israel is
watching
closely and any person Hamas or other
that abuses a hostage we are
watching We are following it closely we
will find them we will punish them they
will not have immunity and if it takes 5
years 10 years or 25 years they will
face Israel's
wroth and the second thing I wanted to
say is what they've done in taking these
hostages is against all Norms of
accepted International Behavior and the
clear demand of the entire International
Community has to be these people must be
released immediately and
unconditionally that should be the
demand of the International Community
everything else is
unacceptable and what would you say to
the relatives and Ames of people who
have been taken hostage I mean is there
much hope for
them we will do everything that is
humanly possible to help bring their
loved ones
home but presumably there would be no
negotiations for this this is this is
purely on a on a on a military basis I
cannot go beyond what I've said and what
do you make of President Biden's
response to what's taking place this
week
the Israelis have
been more than happy and grateful for
the support we've received from
Washington and from the UK for that
matter your foreign secretary was here
yesterday today we had the American
Secretary of State here une equivocal
condemnation of of what Kamas has done
clear differentiation here is a
democratic country defending itself
against a hostile attack there's no
moral equivalency between Israel and
Hamas that is appreciated and the
Americans have done one better by moving
their
forces to the region by moving that
carrier to the Eastern Med and by
supplying resupplying Israel's armaments
okay well look thank you very much for
your time Mark I do really appreciate it
and and all the best my pleasure thank
[Music]
you